a new las vegas startup is working to
bring a boost to local businesses
near me is the name of the app and the
company says it could be especially
helpful now as our economy reopens
oracle mana joining us now live with
more on how it works orca
well denise once you download the near
me app to your smartphone
it will show you the restaurants and
stores that are nearest to you
and the main idea is to bring awareness
to businesses that you might not have
known about and we spoke to one local
restaurant
that hopes it helps
chef nathan asamoto is cooking up some
delicious dishes at his henderson
restaurant eight kitchen but while the
food
sizzles on the grill business is still
trying to heat up
we weren't as busy as we should be
asamoto tells me kofit 19 has caused
fewer customers to come by
especially with eight kitchen tucked
away in this shopping center
especially being a new restaurant and
with kogud happening it you know it made
it really hard for us to you know build
our following and brand and
get ourselves out there asamoto hopes
the las vegas-based app near me can help
it's
an effortless way to be discovered daily
by
locals and visitors founder and ceo
mcriego says the near me app detects
where someone is and then immediately
shows them nearby restaurants and stores
in so many ways near me acts as x-ray
vision for you
the focus right now is on southern
nevada businesses which can add
themselves into the system near me helps
them craft the perfect profile and it's
all for free
the economy is opening back up now is
the perfect time because we really do
want to help small businesses be
discovered more easily
through our platform the ultimate goal
is to bring in more patrons and help
businesses like eight kitchen get past
this pandemic
hopefully you know it'll get us you know
recognized and put us on the map
now businesses who are interested in
getting on the near me app can go to
this
website to sign up you'll be emailed a
startup guide to help you with the
onboarding process
and we have the link that you'll need to
go to to get started on our website
eightnewsnow.com reporting live in the
newsroom tonight orco mana 8 news now